Naughty Dog series like Uncharted and  the last of us are known for their  writing and the team is bringing on even  more talent I'm Tony and this is your  narrative gamespot news update the last  of us part 2 will be co-written by West  worlds Hayley gross she's credited with  writing two of the episodes of the  show's first season along with story  editing to others Last of Us director  Neil druckmann tweeted out the news  adding that the story is very intense  this comes on top of him previously  saying that the story is quote about  hate knowing what Joel and Ellie went  through in the previous game that all  makes sense the last of us part two is  in very early stages of development but  expect to hear plenty about it over the  coming months and you should probably  plan on it being a ps4 exclusive to keep  up with all the latest from Naughty Dog  you're already in the right place  you